walking running throwing striking moving
furniture grappling swimming what all
these things have in common rotation and
yet what is something that we rarely
ever do in the gym or during our
training
hang on
rotate that should be reason enough in
my opinion that should be argument
enough to get you guys to rotate more in
the gym we move in this plane
information all the time we need to be
powerful strong and safe doing so and so
it's nuts to me that it's something that
we don't train I have a perfect exercise
for you guys the crossbody kettlebell
swing that's fantastic for training your
rotational strength your strength and
movement in the transverse plane we'll
get to that in a moment but first I'd
like to quickly address why is that
Sophie people are moving in the
rotational plane in their training to
begin with there's a few reasons for
this the first of course is simply a
lack of awareness this is something that
a lot of people simply don't realize
they need to do and many coaches aren't
going to tell them to rotate either most
of our favorite exercises that we
default to the bench press the curl the
squat the lunge they don't involve
rotation they're all in the sagittal
plane at the same time in order to move
in the rotational plane you need usually
some kind of specialist equipment that
means a cable pulley that means bands or
it means a kettlebell as we're going to
see in a moment on top of this though
those that are in the know some of them
will tell you you don't need to train
the rotational plane they'll say that
when you train in the sagittal plane
you're strengthening those same muscles
even if you aren't moving in those ways
well first of all you're not
strengthening them much I mean you
strengthen your legs when you do a
standing bicep curl because they are
stabilizing muscles you strengthen your
core when you do a standing bicep curl
but I wouldn't call that enough to train
your legs and your core I think most
people would agree with me it's the same
thing if you're doing a squat and
expecting to train your obliques or your
rhomboids or anything like that they
just aren't getting enough dedicated
attention at the same time we also need
to be building these movement patterns
we need to train ourselves to move the
correct muscles in the correct way to
generate maximum power you may have
heard people say that bodybuilders can't
fight despite all the apparent strength
and muscle they have this holds some
truth and the same goes for power
lifters and the most strength athletes
but it's not because of that sport it's
not because they built muscle bulky
muscle as many people seem to think it's
because they're not training themselves
use it properly they're not training
themselves in the transverse plane
they're not learning to develop power in
the feet and hips and throw it into a
punch it's not only about building
strength to match in those muscles that
are responsible for rotating the body
it's about learning that movement
pattern
someone told me in the comments that the
big three lifts from powerlifting take
care of all the big kinetic chain
patterns but I massively disagree with
this because how is rotation how is the
Sarape effect not a big kinetic chain
pattern
migrating somewhere a bit drier I think
finally some people say that you want to
avoid things like rotational kettlebell
swings because they think it's going to
damage their spine they say that you
shouldn't put this spine in a rotated
Twisted position and apply torque
because it's weak in that position and
you can injure yourself but that's
exactly the point because it's weak in
that position and you can injure
yourself that's why we need to
strengthen it this is knees over toes
all over again if your knees are weak
when they go past your toes you don't
just avoid ever training that position
because in real life your knees do go
past your toes as Ben Patrick will point
out when you go down the stairs same
thing goes for rotation I've pointed out
you rotate when you walk when you run
when you throw when you throw a punch
when you grapple when you swim when you
move furniture you're gonna do one of
those things probably the moving
furniture and if you haven't trained at
all in this range of motion chances are
you're gonna hurt yourself so you want
to strengthen ourselves in this movement
pattern with a gentle and correct
movement learning to move properly just
like we do with a deadlift or something
building up strength and stability
stabilizing muscles and then we can use
this power and strength to avoid injury
when we go out into the a real world and
that's why you need rotational movements
it's why they cross the body kettlebell
swings one of my favorite exercises and
we'll see why this one specifically is
fantastic for this in a moment and it's
why it's something I program for
literally everybody so let's take a look
but just as it's important to protect
your spine by using functional exercises
it's also important to protect your skin
with today's sponsor tiege Hanley not
sure whether I should be proud or
ashamed of that segue teach Hanley is a
men's skincare brand that simplifies the
process of looking after your skin they
do this by providing you with all the
products you need and none that you
don't I recommend that you start with
their level 1 system which comes with
all of the basics that's a daily face
wash an exfoliating scrub an AM
moisturizer with SPF 20 at a PM
moisturizer I want to make it really
simple they also include an instruction
card that basically tells you when and
how much and how to apply every single
one of these products this really
appealed to me as someone who is
interested in looking after their skin
especially as I'm getting a little bit
older but who really doesn't want to
spend a whole lot of time researching
all this stuff and I genuinely think
that my skincare has made a difference
to the way I look
so smooth you need to shave though but
don't take just my word for it because
they have over 7 000 positive customer
reviews in addition to amazing skin
members of tea can only get tons of
benefits including at least 20 of the
retail price access to exclusive monthly
deals the ability to pause or cancel at
any time and free us shipping and
because tea channel is sponsoring
today's video they're offering my
viewers an amazing deal just click the
link in the description and you'll get
30 off your first box plus a free gift
don't miss out on this amazing deal
click that link and get started today
so to perform this movement here's what
you're gonna do you're gonna get your
kettlebell
stand
with it hanging nicely in the middle
have a slight Bend in your knees not
major but you want soft knees and then
what you're going to do is you're going
to swing from one side to the other
you're going to do that by starting in
that position
and then I'm going to produce power from
my shoulders and my lats
and the thing to be aware of
is that as my body is crossing over
I'm also rotating at the hips and this
is key
trying to keep the knees in line with
the toes so the whole leg twists
so yeah as I'm swinging across my body I
start producing the movement from my
lats and for my shoulders and then my
torso rotates and joins in producing
power but then what's going to happen is
my hips are going to twist so I'm going
to move like this this is important
because it allows me to keep my lumbar
spine my lower back nice and rigid and
straight because the upper torso the
thoracic spine is designed to rotate and
should be able to generate power that
way you want some nice mobility in that
area to move in a powerful and
functional way but the lumbar spine the
lower back
isn't designed to rotate so much so
that's where an injury can happen what
we want to learn to do is to keep that
relatively locked in place now of course
a little bit rotation is normal if your
body can do something chances are it
should be able to do it
but you don't want to be twisting
here like so you want to be bringing
your whole lower torso around because
that's also going to be what allows you
to produce power from the floor into a
fist into a throw into anything else if
you move like this you lose all of that
power and that energy
what I like about this movement in
particular is firstly like I say the
fact that we're rotating at the hips as
well as the core which I think is a
really key feature at the same time
though I like it because of the
direction the angle of resistance so
when you perform an atlas swing for
example you're swinging it up actually
like this which might be good for a
golfer and it also involves rotating at
the hips but if you're throwing a punch
a ball a piece of furniture if you're
wrestling then you're usually going to
be trying to rotate across the angle of
resistance coming from behind you and
this is why I really like the crossbody
kettlebell swing because although the
angle of resistance is still going down
in many ways because you know gravity
you're still trying to move it in this
horizontal fashion across your body and
of course once the momentum carries the
weight and twists with your body then
the resistance actually is coming in
that direction and pulling you backwards
behind you because it's followed that
Arc through the air and another really
great thing about it is the deceleration
phase because it includes anti-rotation
so as the weight moves you want to
dampen that momentum in order to prevent
it applying too much rotational Force to
your spine and so that you can then
deliver power back the other way and
that means that you're using your
muscles to brace and to slow down the
movement using them very much in a form
of stabilization much like you do with
something like a one ounce push-up
that's a form of anti-rotation fight
against this momentum is trying to twist
your body and then you're delivering it
back the other way it's like you're
battling against the Kettlebell so this
is another great way to prevent injury
because you're learning to absorb impact
and deliver it straight back
of course there's also all kinds of
other bracing going on because you don't
want the weight to pull your forwards
and over you'll still want to lean back
too far and fall over so yeah there's
all kinds of core stabilization going on
here in a very Dynamic manner teaching
you to keep your body stable and to
maintain balance under all these
unpredictable forces killing looking so
good by the way guys don't worry too
much about the naming conventions here
the term crossbody kettlebell swing can
be used for a whole bunch of different
exercises including the kettlebell swing
we just go to one side including the
atlas swing some people probably call
this something different there's no like
Universal agreed name so don't worry too
much about that when it comes to
performing an exercise what's more
important than the specific technique is
the biomechanics and making sure you're
safe what's important here for example
is not allowing too much talk to be
applied to the lumbar spine the lower
back my point is learn the principles
but don't get too wedged to one school
or one idea experiment learn from
different teachers and yeah don't be a
keyboard Warrior I think we ate all the
rolls so that's about it the salami
um do with that as you will now of
course it goes without saying that you
need to use a light weight to begin with
and you can even just practice the
movement
without a weight to start with just to
make sure you've got the movement
pattern down correctly before you then
add on weight so I hope you found this
video useful and interesting guys
actually made it because you requested
that I did I made my video on my top 10
exercises and quite a few of you
requested that I make a highlight on
this exercise so here it is I hope you
found it useful and interesting let me
know if you use in the comments down
below or what other rotational exercises
you use likewise if there's more
exercises you'd like me to do a
highlight and a breakdown on like this
one then let me know and I'll hopefully
get around to it if you want a training
program that includes this movement and
a whole bunch of others that often go
overlooked to develop every aspect of
your performance then I have a program
for that it's called super functional
training 2.0 the protein performance
system there's a link to in the
description down below it comes with
over two hours of instructional footage
and an 80 plus page ebook either way
guys thank you so much for watching this
one and I'll see you next time bye for
now